soda and sugary drinks New York City
Mike Bloomberg this week was about to
have his wish come true which was that
they were not going to be allowed to
serve sodas over 16 ounces in
restaurants and stores bodegas that
whole thing and then at the last second
a judge jumped in and stopped him said
this is not legal and now Americans can
all continue our right to be fat
where do we fall out on this I'm torn
actually cuz like there's a part of me
that one night like there's a great
thing in the in the in the piece I read
earlier 9 out of 10 neighborhoods and
that were the high had the highest
obesity rates in New York City also have
the largest sale of sugary drinks so it
makes sense that there's a correlation
between sugary drinks and obesity and
it's a huge huge problem so like yes but
at the same time I really love fresca
and now fresco would be a would not be a
part of it but like I loved soda and I
want to be able to buy it in any form
size that I want at any place because
I'm an American
Ohio so you're one example is a soda
that wouldn't have but like coca-cola
yeah I want to be able to buy a
coca-cola I get that so I'm torn I don't
know desi what do you think well you
know I I understand why Mayor Bloomberg
is doing this because the cost to the
states from you know chronic health
impacts of the obesity crisis that we
have you know the long-term attempts to
deal with obesity and diabetes you know
especially in children the childhood
obesity epidemic this is gonna cost us a
lot of money as a society overall so I
understand why he's doing it it's just I
know that this is the right mechanism
for it there's so many loopholes into it
you know it has to depend on on what the
New York City has authority over and
there are some places that they don't
have authority over so it's a really
gonna be a mishmash of how they enforce
it on to the other drink yeah you know
contents of the drink is Starbucks I I
saw that at one point Starbucks was
saying well are we gonna be including on
this was saying they weren't gonna do it
they have the money to fight it perhaps
but now at least for now that have to do
that Adam you are a fit man looking at
tried guessing
drink a lot of sugary drink no III think
that if it wasn't for like fat girls
then I'd have a much tougher time in
college you know can you just lay that
logic out again I think that look the
fat girls have a very good purpose in
life and they're good people in general
but sometimes like your girlfriend dumps
you you need to get some ass quickly yes
normally like you need to get some put
some head you know like fat girls are
known to give really good head and then
I'm sure so so that's one of those
things were something you need fat
people love it
when I pull up to a fat person I go hey
where should I eat and he points to the
restaurant I know that person's gonna
know what the good restaurant is like
never like that when I pull up to that
person entity never trust a skinny chef
right you've heard that you know I mean
how are we gonna know what food tastes
good although you do make several good
points there Adam I think doesn't you
hit on what I thought was the most
important part here although I haven't
pulled up to a fat woman lately the idea
that the that because of now Obamacare
let's say for example we're all in this
together now we're all paying taxes into
the system that's gonna give us health
insurance so if the person next to you
is eating poorly you're gonna end up
paying for their health care so doesn't
that give us all a reason to back things
like this even if it doesn't seem like
it adds up yes I think that because I
mean another good point that the law
makes is that the the largest portion of
people who are obese in America are
people who are either in middle class or
lower middle class or poor and these are
the people who are they're forced to buy
I mean a child after school has a choice
of buying a coca-cola or an apple juice
that cost $2 or a coke can that cost $1
they're gonna choose the thing that cost
a dollar and so they're getting obese
from that and because we're paying in
with Obamacare into the system we're
paying for that child's then obesity 20
20 years down the line you're not doing
anything they're going home video games
part of it I drink a lot of soda I eat
like [ __ ] but I I work out and I go to
the gym and I try to run as much as I
can that's really the problem I think is
I think that
the soda isn't the kid you're gonna
drink to saucer or three sodas they're
gonna buy more soda it's not they're not
gonna withhold from soda because it's 20
ounce versus a 16 ounce or a 14 ounce so
that's that mechanism you know is this
the right mechanism for it you know when
you say that we pay into the system for
chronic health impacts we also pay into
the system for farm subsidies you know
we have this corn crop that is pervasive
throughout everything we eat every bit
of processed food and the meat that we
eat is raised on corn as well which is
completely unnatural to what they
evolved just for people that aren't
exactly sure what you're talking about
there's high fructose corn syrup
fructose fructose which one is a Thai
food toast okay I did it last week too
there's corn in our soda people don't
realize you have a soda sprite you're
drinking corn that is crazy that's a
great crop corn is a fabulous crop it
does all kinds of great things but it
the corn system that we have is the
problem there's a great article in The
Economist right now that discusses the
corn system how the subsidies that we
use and the crop insurance program and
various other policies throughout the
Department of Agriculture and of course
you know big biotech companies like
Monsanto you know they all pay their
lobbyists to make sure they get the
kinds of policies that will benefit
their product the most and so you find
here with this new york soda ban that
the beverage industry is a major fighter
for this obviously because that's their
business model so they would fight it
and when you're somebody like a kid in
New York City who only has a dollar to
spend you're the coke is going to cost
you less because it's subsidized by the
rest of us yeah thus proving that
everything comes down to money once
again we do have to move on but just for
the record if you're a overweight chick
and you're into Adam his Twitter handle
is right down there or if you're angry
at him his Twitter handle is also right
down there
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report get this shirt used
code TR are to 0 fa nobis calm